there is a point of so-called Christian
not
wisdom to reach I'm totally opposed I'm
generally a both wisdom I think wisdom
is the most disgusting thing you can
imagine wisdom is the most conformist
thing you can imagine
wisdom is this you know whatever you do
a wise man will come and justify it you
know like you do something risky and you
succeed there will come there will be a
wise man who will come and say something
like I don't know we in Slovene we have
a proverb maybe you have a similar one
only those who risk profit and so on and
so on let's say you do the same thing
but fail a wise man will come and he
will say something like in Slovene we
had vulgar saying which says you cannot
urinate against the wind or something
like that you know this is wisdom
whatever you do a wise guy will come and
and we should not act but it's so
interesting that a philosopher should be
against with them we all are when you're
turkey garden yudhisthira guard was anti
wise men but excellent wisdom is phagon
liquid not going to buy stolen stuff but
what I wanted once I made a mental
experiment if you don't believe me let's
take I will say something I will say I
don't know how to say it I'm to ironic
with all these pathos you know why are
we why are we running after this
miserable earthly pleasures think about
eternity the only satisfaction is
eternity if I were to say it with proper
pathos it would sound the deep thing to
say it sounded let's say the opposite
why run after the specter of eternity
per diem grasp what you have here it
sounds wise now I will say the third
option
why decode in a contrast between
intermediate temporary existence the
drew wisdom is to see eternity in
fleeting temporary pleasures
it is wise then I say the fort variation
we are forever
between the two wise men except this you
know whatever I say that's my point you
can sell it as a wisdom this is a wisdom
and if from no one else from your
Kierkegaard you can learn this that
whatever Jesus Christ was he wasn't a
wise guy